hey welcome to the second season and boy
doesn't this one start out on a high
note that boy what's this up this is a
good start this is a really good start
to this season first of all yeah I knew
it man I knew that girl is gonna come
back um that that is a Zula that is the
sister of Zuko and obviously once you
know that it's like oh dude these that
they're gonna be enemies my guess is
face burn you know she's like yeah yeah
teach him dad um so so she's now
character is supposed to go and pretty
much hunt down Zuko and his uncle
because the father's like I'm sick of
him I want him out
I don't want mucking things up um so so
she looks like it's gonna be the
prominent villain now and we also have
at the end of this episode we we get
Zuko and the uncle um if I read it right
it looks like they cut off
so for Zuko all that's left of his hair
and for the uncle that they both cut off
their ponytails which I'm assuming means
they're just believing the Fire Nation
um and which would be interesting to see
where they where they go with that uh
but on top of that he also had this
great story going on with Aang trying to
figure out why does he become you know
what I guess they call now the Avatar
state uh when's eyes glowing the tattoos
glow and so they take to this kid you
know it just it just hit me like didn't
it hurt him it never actually hit me and
though I thought about that but okay so
so bottom line yeah he glows and becomes
all-powerful and they come across this
desert bending nation or the
earthbending colony that wants to go
back to the Fire Nation they're tired of
this war they're tired of people dying
for this war and they figure the sooner
they can get the avatar to figure out
how to do this avatar state like you did
at the end of the last season the sooner
they can stop all this killing and
that's really tough for
again it's a great responsibility for
our main character much more than the
man is still I didn't mana steel
talk about this am sorry as I'm
recording this it's still a few days
that just he-man is table um but yeah is
so you have this uh you have this
responsibility that he's toying with
that he knows he's not quite ready or at
least he doesn't have it under control
actually it's to a point where now he's
he's afraid of the power because he's
not in control of it and he's having bad
dreams and he's not in control like it
will hurt things and people that he
holds very dear so that can be you know
that's something to be cautious of but
the same time every minute he's not
doing it more and more people are dying
and you know that's a good that's a good
die lemma there and it's very hard to
choose and and Katara has her thoughts
and he has his thoughts and then they're
trying to figure it out uh and the earth
nation or the earth bending nation the
King VII is like so it only works if you
seem to be an incredible danger okay and
tries to tries to kick his ass pretty
much it basically tries to kill him to
get him to release this and when he
finds out that's not working a great
lies as you can't run forever and Hank
says you can't fight forever that's the
good line there uh so comes across
Katara she tries to help and he realizes
await if I sink her you know he'll
probably that'll get a meadow get him
crazy ants a very intense scene I mean
like you sort of know they're not gonna
kill her off I mean it just seemed very
unlikely but they again especially for a
kitchen they were really hammering in
you know sort of the the heart pounding
there you know that she's sinking closer
and closer and he's saying given to the
Amazon
even to this day given to the you know
she will die she will die and he's
trying he doesn't know how he's tearing
up is this his guy it's a very intense
scene um and of course she's fine
I don't know how he just pulled her out
of the ground is a little weird but you
know what are the fancy I had on a high
works um so again we see him we see him
go nuts at a moment I think it's only
the second time where he unleashes this
and it's not really called for it that
the first time was when he saw his old
master the body of his old master and
then this time all the other times it
was to save the day or or get out of a
situation here you know those are two
times is just pure anger is pure emotion
uh and there was no real responsibility
to it oh you could almost argue but no
she's he thinks she's dead so you know
this was something he couldn't control
and thus he can't control he dream uh CH
wipes out a good chunk of that city and
he sees the damage he's caused and again
it just reiterates how important it is
for him to understand this and get under
control Oh God then they find out this
horrible news the this information that
if he's in this state and he's killed
the reincarnation will no longer happen
so even when he does it he has to be
really careful about now granted he's
like this really unstoppable thing you
know I mean it's unlikely someone would
or could kill him but at the same time
it's like dude that's even more pressure
to throw on this so I really like that
they're throwing he's getting more and
more of this responsibility and trying
to understand it and they're showing it
they don't just throw stuff they don't
just throw rules and then he has to you
know learn by them or whatever they're
giving time to let those rules and those
emotions sink in and what it means and
the responsibility uh because that
that's what you would do if you heard
this news
you had these abilities and these you
know this new information was brought to
light that could seriously damage you if
not kill you or damage and kill others
close to you you would take the time to
sit down and really think it out and I
like that they show him doing that they
show all the characters doing that
that's something this show has I think
over many other uh and that just kids
action shows I should say shows that
emphasize uh the adventure aspect and
they do show they do take the time to
show them having it really sinking and
having conversations about it and
discussing it so I really like that and
it's always it's made better that it's
with kids because again that's good role
model for kids and then I want the fact
that not just kids but adults I love the
fact that shows ahead I'm glad that this
really caught on because there is so
much smart stuff and it really deserves
it deserves the attention again so I'm
really happy about that something I do
realize though is that okay you got the
fire Lord he says I'm done with my
brothers betrayed me and my nephew
betrayed me yeah you my daughter you
must go and destroy them and bring them
back so we can keep them in prison they
won't be doing any more harm and stuff
you know the general that general Malfoy
guy I never did learn his name I'm sorry
but he's saying you know I what the
avatar is just a kid ha we can get him
and then when Zuko comes he's like you
know I can't have a teenager trying to
tell me what to do and stuff it seems
like this Fire Nation is right it's
being run by mostly kids yeah you got
Zuko
you got the daughter or make you know
the avatar is a kid so I don't know what
the big problem is I just assume that
most of the kids in this world are like
running half the stuff um but again I I
like especially for a kids show I like
that the adults really do respect the
kids and they do listen to them and they
emit
respects they do treat them very much
like adults but not forgiving that they
are children that they are learning so
it's it's still aware that they are
children but it still treats them with a
lot of dignity and I think that's
important I think that's very important
for kids shows and movies anything uh
you know that's entertainment for kids
so I think that's about it for this
episode it's just it late on a lot of
good information there there's again
good action in it good good stuff with
the villains I like this new villain
although you know last thing I'll ask
about our talk if I should say you can't
respond I'm a video you can't I want to
hear you um so I guess now they can
control electricity or at least this
Zula character is learning how to
control electricity as well as fire and
it did make me sir question where is
electricity in this world cuz it seems
like it doesn't exist you know like
there's a lot of places they light
torches and everything's made out of
rock and wood and such but then again
they have subs and they're you think
there had to be some electricity on that
damn thing so I am wondering how exactly
this works but I'm sure they'll go into
it I like seeing her learn this and zuko
seems legitimately shocked that she
could do this um but I like that the
uncles seem to know it too I liked when
she was gonna do the the shock there
that the uncle grant the hand is shouted
out of his hand I thought that was
pretty cool we did see that one other
time didn't we when like lightning
struck or something like that so I mean
this isn't entirely foreign but again
it's just another another little
addition to add there to make those
story more interesting and throwing more
twists and turns so yeah it's a great
start I really want to see where this is
going to go and they established so much
in this first episode but they didn't
they didn't hammer it in too much and
they let it sink in with everybody too
they let them really realize what every
choice means and what it's going to
result in so I really like
SEPA so a lot I thought was very very
well done the Avatar State if I if I
didn't say that title yet so yes really
enjoyed it
yeah episode 2 of season 2